Ce samedi sur RFI Éco
d'ailleurs, Bruno Faure. Il est
surnommé le loup de la finance
africaine ou l'homme aux
chaussettes rouges. Stanislas
Zézé est cette semaine le grand
invité de l'économie RFI Jeune
Afrique. À l'origine de la
première agence de notation sur
le continent, cet Ivoirien
cosmopolite propose une
information stratégique pour
les cadres et les dirigeants.
Écodissieurs avec la BOAD. Tous
les samedis à dix heures dix TU
sur RFI. RFI et France 24
présentent
Radio Foot International, le
Café des sports, Annie Gasnier
Bonjour à tous et bienvenue
dans le Café des Sports de
Radio Foot International et de
France 2022 vous pouvez nous
suivre vous le savez un peu
partout que ce soit à la radio,
que ce soit sur internet ou
encore à la télévision. Nos
invités sont là euh, la caméra
ne peut le cacher, la radio le
cache plus mais pas la la télé
Xavier la caméra alors je vous
présente tout de suite nos deux
amis, toujours très élégants,
je dois le dire, bonjour Xavier
Barret et bonjour Rémy. Bonjour
Annie. Salut on dirait m'a
copié aujourd'hui. Vous êtes
dans laiton euh, c'est pas tu
vois là il y a toi tu es en
couleur unique j'évolue d'une
autre dans une autre dimension.
Jérémie est toujours dans le
détail bien entendu, vous en
avez l'habitude et puis il y a
l'homme aux yeux bleus
désormais. Bonjour Frédéric.
Bonjour Annie, bonjour Xavier.
et les auditeursqui sont déjà
là, la page euh, ouais c'est
parti, Yémen euh, il y a Founa,
salut l'équipe géniale de Radio
Foot, Placide euh, force à vous
éminents journalistes euh, bon
on prend hein, le le
compliment. Euh, encore un un
coucou de Alan Sch Joseph il
nous dit je vous suis depuis
Haïti, il est vrai quà cause
de la pénurie de carburant, les
stations de radio n'émettent
plus mais n'empêche, je vous
suis sur Facebook. Donc lui
n'écoute que dans une station
le pauvre. Il a du mérite parce
que c'est compliqué hein.
Alors, qu'y aura-t-il dans nos
débats du jour? Eh bien, nous
parlerons d'abord des chocs du
week-end et il y en a
évidemment à travers l'Europe.
Nous commencerons en Allemagne.
En Allemagne, avec un
classiqueur à Dortmund au pied
du mur jaune où le Borussia
reçoit les Xavier bavarois.
Enjeux, les commandes,
justement, de la Bundesliga. À
Londres, les Gunners face aux
Reds Arsenal jouera pour
conserver la tête de la
Première Ligue, alors que
Liverpool cherche à rebondir.
Dans le nord de la France, le
derby des Ch'tis, Lille lance
les sang et or, mieux classés
et désormais sans Gaël Kakuta
domineront-ils les Dogues? La
technologie encore plus
présente au prochain mondial.
On nous promet un hors-jeu
semi-automatisé en plus de
l'avare. Mais qu'est-ce que ça
peut bien être? Adios sel
pépite avant même de terminer
sa saison sous le maillon rose
de l'Inter Milan.
L'international argentin
Gonzalo Higuain a annoncé sa
retraite, un buteur passé par
les plus grands clubs,
notamment le Réal, Rémy, mais
sans avec l'Albi Celeste et et
cela est malheureusement une
euh un caillou dans sa
chaussure ou dans son crampon
au générique de cette
démission, David Finzel et euh
Sarah Lou Baccouche, Laurence
Allerno à la réalisation de
l'émission, il y a aussi pour
ce qui est de la vidéo, Swel
Khedir et Léo Bernard, le Café
des sports, nos débats sont
ouverts.
c'est donc au pied d'un mur
jaune qui chante vous venez de
l'entendre lui aussi le Yule
Never Walker si cher à
Liverpool que se disputera donc
le premier des classiqueurs de
cette saison, ça sera samedi
soir enfin samedi en fin
d'après-midi seize heures
trente TU Dortmund et le Bayern
Munich vivent euh on peut dire
un peu en parallèle un début de
saison, pas aussi euh
époustouflant ou clinquant que
les autres saisons, on alterne
le bon et le moins bon on va
dire. ils ne sont pas encore
aux commandes de de la du
championnat comme ça se passe
euh pourtant régulièrement mais
ils sont sur le point
évidemment de se rapprocher des
deux premières équipes, l'Union
de Berlin et Fribourg qui les
devance de deux points au terme
de ce classiqueur. Le Bayern
alors évidemment aimerait
rester sur sa dynamique, ils
viennent de remporter deux
belles victoires, une en
championnat contre le Bayern et
une autre en Ligue des
champions, ils ont marqué 9
buts au total sur ces deux
matchs et en plus Kinsley
revient. Ils sont cependant au
coude à coude, même nombre de
points avec le BVB qui compte,
lui, sur sa jeunesse.
Évidemment, euh pour dévorer
l'ordre, l'ordre bavarois.
Alors, Rémy, est-ce que vous
diriez que dans ce classiqueur
euh on peut accorder euh
avantage à ceux qui reçoivent,
c'est-à-dire euh à Dortmund
? Non. Non. Bon. Euh je je
n'accorde pas l'avantage là
parce que le Bayern est en
train de revenir très très
fort. Et c'est pour ça que je
dis que oui mais deux matchs
mais surtout il y a un détail,
c'est que on avait une plainte
au niveau du Bayern , à savoir
que on ne trouvait pas des
buteurs. Or là maintenant oui
qui lui faisait du travail tout
seul. Voilà il faisait tout
seul. Mais là vous voyez que
lors des derniers matchs vous
avez non seulement Sadio Mané
qui retrouve les filets, vous
avez pratiquement tiré le Roi
même prévenu qui a marqué
également donc du coup tous les
attaquants des remplaçants des
attaquants ont réussi à
marquer. Lorsque vous êtes dans
cette dynamique-là et que vous
êtes en pleine euphorie, il est
beaucoup plus avantageux pour
vous de pouvoir enchaîner que
de pouvoir encore tomber. Donc
aujourd'hui, que ce soit sur le
plan défensif et non pas
concédé vraiment assez
d'occasions. Ils ont été
dominateurs, ils ont été
souverains au niveau du milieu
de terrain. Et du coup, je
trouve quand même que ce Bayern
retrouver euh Xavier on
commence l'émission mais c'est
vrai que mais Xavier le Bayern
certes euh mais euh de l'autre
côté on a aussi euh gagné très
largement à Séville euh le
Dortmund à la responsabilité
d'avoir fait tomber euh Julien
c'est une plaisanterie parce
que ça venait de loin mais en
tout cas c'est à la suite de ce
match, ils ont gagné quatre un
et c'est vrai que aussi euh ils
ont des des jeunes euh qui sont
talentueux et on pense euh à
l'anglais il dort peut
effectivement maintenir un peu
de suspense dans le la
Bundesliga euh jusqu'au des
titres tant mieux et je le
souhaite vraiment mais euh euh
Dortmund a déjà concédé quatre
défaites cette saison, toutes
compétitions confondues, ils
ont perdu à Manchester City en
Ligue des champions, ils ont
perdu contre le VAR Brème, ils
ont perdu euh contre le RB
Leipzig et ils ont perdu contre
Cologne lors de la dernière
journée de championnat. Euh le
Bayern n'a eu qu'un accident,
c'est à Hautsbourg, sinon ils
ont fait des matchs nuls.
Effectivement ils en ont fait
trois contre Bernard et
Stuttgart. Mais quand le Bayern
se retrouve face à un
adversaire de son niveau, que
ce soit au niveau européen euh
et vous là vous avez leur euh
leurs euh résultats euh contre
le Barça par exemple ou
l'Inter, ils ont gagné à chaque
fois deux zéro ou que ce soit
en Munich ils ont gagné très
fort à Francfort dès la
première journée six un
Francfort qui avait gagné la la
Ligue Europa dès qu'il y a un
enjeu ils ont besoin de ils
s'imposent. Les les accidents
qu'ils ont eu, c'est un peu
comme le PSG en en ligue un, en
général, c'est là où on les
attend pas, à Ausbourg,
effectivement ils perdent, la
saison dernière ils avaient
perdu Hoffenheim, euh alors euh
tout le monde est ah ça y est,
c'est ben oui puis derrière ils
avaient battu euh je sais plus
si c'était Leverkusan ou
Leipzig, dès qu'ensuite ils se
retrouvent dans un match au il
s'impose. C'est pour ça que je
crains que ce soit très
compliqué pour euh pour euh le
BVB, pour Dortmund malgré le
soutien du public. Frédéric euh
les les quelques hum
interrogations qu'on a autour
de du Bayern certes, c'est euh
évidemment le le départ de
Lewandowski et on savait pas
trop encore qui prendrait euh
son rôle, pas son poste, mais
son rôle mais euh c'est-à-dire
un rôle de buteur, mais il y a
aussi sur autour de
l'entraîneur Julien, il y a il
y a pas encore une unanimité.
Il il il séduit pas encore euh
ou il ne convainc pas encore,
on a l'impression que c'est
dirigeants? Ben peut-être qu'on
attend euh une grande épopée en
en Ligue des champions. Non
mais c'est vrai que c'est c'est
pas en Bundesliga euh qu'il est
attendu pour pour faire ses
preuves euh Nagal Smann. Et en
Ligue des champions, vous le
rappeliez, pour l'instant,
c'est un parcours parfait,
hein, et est-ce qu'on s'alarme
pas pour euh pas grand chose
finalement? Euh le Bayern est
habitué à ses débuts de saison,
parfois, non pas poussifs, mais
bon, il faut mettre la machine
en route. On l'a dit, il y a eu
le départ de Lewandowski, Sadio
Mané, alors il y a eu cinq
matchs sans marquer à un moment
donné, là, mais bon, euh c'est
reparti depuis le le week-end
dernier, on est quand même pas
trop inquiets pour la la
machine euh Bayern euh
de Munich euh on attend du jeu
hein, il est là pour ça,
normalement hein on pour faire
bien jouer euh cette cette
équipe-là. Euh les auditeurs
ils sont pas inquiets du tout
hein. Euh le classiqueur est
déjà joué, on connaît déjà le
vainqueur, nous dit Boubakar,
dit allô. Euh le Bayern euh est
reparti avec Mané également,
réaction euh qui nous vient de
de Dakar et puis José euh
Obeltrane, c'est le seul, lui,
nous dit victoire de Dortmund
trois buts à deux. Hum hum. Il
mise sur la jeunesse donc. Non
mais pourquoi pas
contraire même serait
compliqué. Alors voilà pour euh
ça sera donc euh ça en samedi
en fin d'après-midi mais à
Londres il y a aussi euh eh
bien euh un match très attendu
et on va le voir pas de cadeau
aux canonniers.
Alors pour ce qui est
d'Arsenal, après avoir disputé
le week-end dernier euh le
derby du nord de Londres euh
contre Tottenham et l'avoir
remporté euh assez brillamment
hein sur le score de 3 à un, eh
bien les Gunners recevront sur
leur pelouse dimanche en fin
d'après-midi Liverpool les
Reds. Une affiche a priori
prometteuse euh euh de choc
mais verra-t-on un choc? C'est
peut-être la question qu'on
peut se poser parce que là
aussi euh des c'est un peu des
deux équipes qui sont peut-être
à la croisée euh
leur destin récent euh cette
équipe d'Arsenal euh qui
n'arrivait pas à s'accrocher au
Bigfort, qui manque euh souvent
euh la Ligue des champions et
puis de en face eh bien des
Reds qui euh jusqu'à présent
bataillaient fermes avec les
Citizens Xavier un petit peu
moins bien euh les Reds n'ont
signé que deux victoires en
cette rencontre, ils ont peiné
la semaine dernière encore
contre Brighton alors que les
Gunners eux avec un peu de
panache eh bien ils arrivent à
gagner, ils taquinent
Manchester City, ils sont deux
points, deux point
hein, si je ne m'abuse. Euh les
Reds euh ont-ils besoin euh eux
aussi d'adversité euh élevée
pour euh pour marquer leur et
se rapprocher surtout au
classement euh Xavier? Euh ils
ont surtout besoin de points
d'écart entre les deux ils ont
surtout besoin de fraîcheur
parce que le le jeu prôné par
euh par par club, par Jogan
Klub demande énormément
d'énergie et on a vu, il y a eu
des blessés, il y a eu euh le
départ de Sadio Mané, il a
fallu euh recaler un peu le le
mode de fonctionnement de
l'équipe. Et pour le moment,
ils sont à la peine. Moi, je
franchement, je les attendais
pas dans le dur comme ça. Mais
bon, euh en plus, la trêve euh
internationale, qui est pas une
trêve en Angleterre, d'ailleurs
ils appellent ça la parce que
c'est la fenêtre internationale
parce qu'en fait tous les
internationaux partent par la
fenêtre ou par la porte, ils
vont jouer et ils voilà. Donc
et notamment Liverpool a
beaucoup d'internationaux. Donc
euh donc euh ça va être un un
match très important pour les
Reds parce que on sait que là
on a vu en Ligue des champions
contre les Glassgo RADIO ils
étaient au-dessus, ils se sont
imposés sans trop de mais
seulement 2zéro presque petits
bras. Euh donc là ça va être un
test important parce depuis le
début de saison, ils sont pas
convaincants et ça va être
aussi un test pour Arsenal on a
hâte d'y être. Rémy qu'en
pensez-vous de ce test? Parce
que c'est vrai que alors si les
Red on les attendait pas euh où
ils sont, peut-être qu'Arsenal
on les attendait pas non plus
où ils sont, c'est-à-dire euh
après des mois ou finalement
Arteta a eu le temps de
préparer son équipe et de et de
la de la peau peut-être mais
lui euh il se retrouve euh
premier depuis pratiquement le
début de saison. Un auditeur
qui nous dit je veux une
réponse de Rémi Xavier est
sage? Oh! C'est le défi
Réalisation Euh je je je vais
dire que euh s'il faut être euh
objectif pour l'instant, moi je
ne regarde que d'autres choses
qui sur le plan sportif sont
très importants, à savoir la
préparation physique.
Athlétique. Arsenal
aujourd'hui. N'a pas une grande
équipe lorsque vous regardez
sur le papier. Mais justement,
c'est une équipe qui sur le
plan physique a réussi à être
sur le point. Je peux par
exemple vous prendre Arsenal
depuis peut-être deux013, 2-014
même, deux-mille-quinze,
deux-mille-seize, prenons même
avec Arteta c'était quoi?
C'était une bande de vieux
chevaux blessés. C'est-à-dire
que il totalisait 967
blessures. Et du coup, par
exemple, lorsqu'ils sont
humiliés avec euh le Bayern oui
oui, c'est comme ça, il y avait
beaucoup non été au milieu du
terrain. Donc c'est assez
qu'époque là qu'il y avait les
Diaby c'était les quand vous
regardiez même VAR mais cette
équipe-là devait remporter le
championnat. Mais qu'est-ce qui
se trouve euh qu'est-ce qu'on
avait? On se rendait compte que
la préparation foncière n'était
pas bien faite. C'est ça que je
dis souvent, ce qui arrive au
Real Madrid, c'est-à-dire que
que ce soit avec euh euh
Zinedine Zidane, que ce soit
avec Carlo Arseloti, la
préparation physique est très
importante pour que les joueurs
arrivent étant au point
aujourd'hui. Quand que les
équipes ont eu le temps
justement Rémi regardez
aujourd'hui le nombre
d'équipes, quand vous regardez
l'équipe de Klaps c'est une
équipe qui n'a pas connu une
préparation physique, c'est une
équipe pratiquement lessivée,
laminée sur le plan athlétique
avec un salaire qui a marqué
deux buts lors des sept
derniers matchs et qui ne
parvient pas à faire des
différences parce qu'on sent
qu'il manque de l'oxygène alors
que la jeunesse d'Arsenal
aujourd'hui est beaucoup plus
enthousiaste mais sauf que
jusque aussi et c'est là où il
y aura un problème, c'est que
Arsenal aime jouer au ballon et
aussi de l'autre côté on
constate quand même que la
version de Klap aujourd'hui
vaut aussi la possession et
c'est là où on va voir sur le
plan tactique qui va piéger
l'autre. Mais pour l'instant je
crois que Arsenal a réussi à
faire un parcours qui peut être
exceptionnel mais on a vu
comment est-ce qu'ils sont
tombés devant Manchester United
dont je ne peux pas encore
applaudir pour être Xavier
parce qu'ils le veulent très
très bien et il y a un problème
africain qui dit on ne décore
pas les soldats avant la fin de
la guerre. Joli proverbe,
Frédéric euh il y a d'autres
commentaires de nos auditeurs
Xavier les les supporters
d'Arsenal euh je suis supporter
d'Arsenal mais j'ai peur pour
demain, c'est quand même
Liverpool euh Johan Félix nous
dit euh avec ce Liverpool là
pour une fois Arsenal aura sa
chance euh Moustapha Koné
encore on aura un choc qui
débouchera sur beaucoup de
buts, quatre ou cinq vous
verrez et cetera et cetera et
puis des pronostics, on va les
battre euh en parlant de
Liverpool, trois un pour
Arsenal Xavier Arsenal
Liverpool trois 1 pour les Red
hein Xavier après l'échec
contre Manchester United parce
qu'ils avaient bien joué les
Gunners ils méritaient de
gagner puis ils ont ils ont été
battus mais depuis il y a eu ce
match contre Totten et le
Tottenham de d'Antonio Conté
c'est justement l'équipe la
pire pour Arsenal qui est une
équipe joueuse, c'est une
Tottenham, c'est une équipe de
contre avec des vrais buteurs,
des garçons qui vont très vite
en contre comme euh et ils ont
ils ont gagné et ils ont gagné
cet arsenal-là non seulement à
la fraîcheur, mais en plus il a
maintenant la confiance et donc
moi je je crois vraiment que le
travail d'Arteta est en train
de payer puis il y a un élément
que n'a pas évoqué Rémy Gunner
mais qui va euh dans le bon
sens c'est que euh Arsenal et
qu'en en Ligue Europa et cette
semaine ils ont joué contre qui
contre euh voilà donc ils ont
gagné l'argent alors que dans
le même temps Liverpool bon a a
a joué dès mardi mais c'était
les Glasgow RADIO même si c'est
pas une équipe extraordinaire
donc donc a priori il y a bon
c'est assez équilibré sur cette
semaine mais le fait qu'Arsenal
ne soit pas en Ligue des
champions pour le moment ils
vont y revenir moi j'y crois
vraiment euh eh bien euh leur
laisse un peu plus de
possibilités de récupérer,
d'être plus frais pour les
matchs du championnat
d'Angleterre. Nous verrons donc
ça en fin de semaine. En
Italie, demain, en fin
d'après-midi, il y aura un
attrayant, Milan AC Juventus,
Matteo Chofi nous en dira plus
euh sur ce match au sommet dans
les prochains jours, selon euh
la teneur euh du match. Parce
que nous, nous en France avons
un derby et c'est dans le nord
le pays des ch'tis. de créer
une Xavier Qui ne saute pas
Qui ne saute pas L'accent euh
ch'ti dans les travées euh du
stade et de nouveau hein les
les supporters de Lens ont le
droit de retourner euh du côté
de Lille, il y aura donc des
supporters lensois. Les Dogues
et leurs visiteurs donc les
sang et or qui euh refermeront
cette euh dixième journée, ça
sera dimanche soir. Le LOSC
réussira-t-il à inverser la
tendance? Parce que l'année
dernière en euh championnat et
Coupe de France compris, il y a
eu 3 rencontres, trois derby du
nord et les trois remportés par
Lens. Le RC Lens dirigé par
Franck Haze, semble aussi fort.
Alors est-ce que euh selon vous
les Lillois peuvent mettre fin
euh Frédéric? Est-ce que les
Lillois peuvent mettre fin à
cette série euh de défaite euh
face à Lens? Non je pense pas.
Euh la dynamique elle est
clairement du du côté des
Lensois hein, on aurait pu dire
euh août, septembre, c'est
c'est le tube de de l'été,
c'est qui a prolongé euh la
communion avec le le public.
Ils n'ont pas perdu un match.
Depuis le début du du
championnat, euh c'est c'est
lensois, ils n'ont rien à
perdre, tout fonctionne. Alors
bon, il y a quand même le le
départ du directeur sportif,
là. Qui est parti du du côté de
Nice euh, bon on se demande un
peu pourquoi Xavier nous en
dire un peu plus, c'est
peut-être la seule chose qui
pourrait les déstabiliser en en
interne mais non, Lens a a
vraiment euh, tout pour quel
poste? Pour la saison Réalis
prolonger ceux qui voulaient
certain et lui-même s'en est
expliqué, c'est que en partant
maintenant, c'est là où il
impacte le moins la vie du
Racing Club de Lens parce que
effectivement euh la période
des transferts est terminée, et
puis d'ici le marché d'hiver,
il y a, ils ont le temps de se
réorganiser à Lens, et
d'ailleurs ils envisagent de
prendre le directeur sportif de
Brest pour le remplacer. Donc
bon, voilà, donc euh oui, donc
c'est c'est certain que les les
les euh directeurs sportifs qui
arrivent à faire des bons
recrutements comme l'a fait
Florent Guizolfi depuis trois
ou quatre ans à à à Lens, euh
ben forcément euh ils
intéressent les qui ont plus
d'argent et c'est le cas de
Nice, euh qui en revanche est
un peu dans la panade. Ouais.
Donc euh qu'on peut voir
derrière nous euh ces bons
recrutements chaque année quoi.
Bien sûr, mais l'équipe elle,
les joueurs qui la fait venir,
et l'entraîneur, ils sont
toujours là, c'est pour ça que
moi sur cette dynamique, je
pense que Lens peut continuer à
à embêter Lille, bon bien sûr,
on sera on sera euh au stade de
Lille mais mais il y a quand
même cette dynamique incroyable
du côté de Lens et surtout, il
y a eu des départs de joueurs
euh bien sûr, il y a eu
Jonathan Klaus qui est parti à
à à Marseille, à Café qui qui
jouent plus, il y a eu euh des
des changements presque le
gardien de but, il y a eu des
changements pratiquement dans
toutes les lignes, mais il y a
eu cette intelligence de
recrutement qui fait que les
les recrues ont ont pris
immédiatement la place des
joueurs qui sont partis et et
et ils ont naturellement trouvé
leur place dans ce système. Euh
avec cet état d'esprit et je
pense que de ce côté-là, Lens a
mieux réussi ces période de
transition que Lille qui était
champion il y a deux ans et qui
maintenant est une équipe qui
est redevenue une équipe de
milieu de tableau. Rémy,
Gaëlle, Kakuta euh qui était
pris euh Marc Vivien Foët en en
20vingt c'était euh
deux-mille-vingt-et-un pardon,
c'était euh le le prix euh donc
du meilleur joueur africain de
de ligue un, Congolais. Il a
décidé de partir, il est parti
ces dernières heures euh du
côté d'Amiens, Amiens euh qui
est retombé en Ligue deux mais
qui est deuxième de la Ligue
deux, qui sera peut-être de
nouveau euh en Ligue 1 l'année
prochaine. Est-ce que c'est la
préretraite pour ce joueur? On
sait qu'il y a un accord aussi
pour euh être dans
l'encadrement sans doute euh
ces prochains temps? Je crois
que c'est quand même une
déception aussi hein parce que
euh je j'attendais à ce qu'elle
puisse beaucoup évoluer Mais il
a de la concurrence sur son
poste je crois que justement.
Le petit club. Euh oui mais je
crois que il y a beaucoup de
concurrence mais euh pas trop
de concurrence même devant.
Parce que Lens même si Lens
joue bien au football c'est
d'abord une équipe aussi qui
défend très très bien le
pasteur c'est la troisième euh
défense de de la ligue un. Euh
donc moi je me dis que sur le
plan offensif il avait bien des
possibilités de pouvoir aimer
euh euh et maire mais je crois
que c'est aussi un certain
manque de de sérieux au travail
qui fait de telle sorte et qui
ne puisse pas progresser comme
ça, d'autres qui avaient moins
de talent ont évolué plus que
lui encore que Lens est une
équipe qui réussit beaucoup
presque euh euh à toute cette
communauté-là, il retrouve euh
rapidement des gens qui ont
presque la même culture que
lui, mais je ne sais pas
pourquoi est-ce qu'il n'a pas
réussi à s'imposer là-bas,
c'est malheureusement ça, il
est en train de griller sa
carrière, c'est presque déjà
imposé quand même euh une ou
deux saisons, on l'a vu euh
fort brillant euh au moins de
saison, mais c'est vrai qu'on
avait
il est revenu euh assez tard
euh dans pour son âge euh du
côté de Lens. Non les les les
auditeurs. téléspectateurs qui
saluent euh le boulot de Franck
hein, l'entraîneur euh une Gary
Traoré, le coach de Lens fait
vraiment un super boulot et
puis fait ça le salé qui nous
dit Franck Haze n'est-il tout
simplement pas le meilleur
entraîneur de la Ligue un? Ah!
En ce moment eu ce débat euh
bon. Rémi, une question moi sur
Lille, est-ce que euh on peut
se dire que Lille vit encore
l'après Galtier? C'est-à-dire
euh parce que finalement, quand
quand ils ont le titre, euh ils
gagnent euh le le championnat
de France avec Christophe
Galtier et depuis il y a eu
Jocelyn Gourvennec l'année
dernière, là ils ont changé de
nouveaux entraîneurs et tout et
on on sent que Lille est encore
euh très très perturbée par
tout ça, ils sont huitièmes du
championnat, c'est ils ont pas
de de très beaux résultats, ils
sont pas du tout européens
cette saison. Je crois même
neuvième, donc enfin je crois
que Lille aujourd'hui c'est
vrai quand même que c'est une
équipe qui déçoit beaucoup,
surtout là où elle faisait
Milodiop, comme j'ai toujours
dit une bonne commence d'abord
par la défense. Aujourd'hui
lorsque vous vous rendez compte
quand même que si l'île a
marqué 7 buts, ils en ont pris
dix-huit C'est énormissime,
c'est une sorte de passoire, il
n'y a pratiquement rien. Moi
j'ai toujours utilisé le
problème, c'est que lorsque la
**** a la queue coupée, tous
les chiens viennent y monter.
Donc aujourd'hui lorsque vous
regardez l'équipe de Lille,
vous sentez que on peut marquer
à tout moment, il n'y a pas ce
qu'on peut appeler un bloc il y
a une porosité incroyable et
c'est pour ça que je dis que
même la c'est vrai que Galtier
ne fait pas aussi mieux
actuellement au Paris
Saint-Germain parce qu'on voit
quand même aussi que la défense
de Paris prend beaucoup de buts
mais tout au moins quand on
voit ce qui se passe à Lille je
suis véritablement très
inquiet. Après il faut il faut
rappeler une chose c'est qu'il
reste plus beaucoup des
champions de France d'il y a
deux ans dans l'effectif du
LOSC Jonathan. Il reste euh
fonte et il reste Benjamin
André euh David il arrive il a
remplacé aux Xavier donc il y a
il y a des des joueurs,
beaucoup de joueurs qui sont
partis de Jonathan Bamba est
encore là, mais sinon il y a eu
beaucoup de renouvellement et
pas forcément euh parce que
forcément quand vous vendez vos
meilleurs joueurs, vous
racheter des joueurs qui sont
un petit peu moins bons, enfin
ou en tout cas un peu moins
chers. Et donc pour le moment
ben le LOSC eh ben ils sont en
train de payer euh cet ce titre
qui a été un peu gagné à crédit
sous la direction de du du
l'actuel président de Girondin
de Bordeaux. Je parlais de
Christophe euh Galtier, eh bien
euh parlons justement euh de
l'entraîneur du Paris
Saint-Germain. Juste pour vous
signaler que tout à l'heure,
enfin de de conférence de
presse euh puisqu'il joue euh
contre Reims euh au cours du
week-end et bien Xavier a
annoncé que son équipe se
déplacera en car. Bravo.
Jusqu'à Xavier à une heure et
demie de Paris hein donc euh
c'est pas très quart d'heure
hein. Oui
avec leur jet privé l'autre
fois ils étaient allés à Lille
en bus en car. Oui donc faudra
poser la question oui. Allez on
continue.
installée depuis 208 lors du
cinquième match du mondial en
Russie, c'était le match France
Australie et un penalty avait
été accordé à la France. Eh
bien euh ce système c'était
l'Avare bien sûr, la vidéo
assistance, celle qui aide les
arbitres et cette VAR sera
évidemment bien présente à la
Coupe du monde mais alors avec
un plus, alors toujours plus
vite, plus loin, plus fort hein
euh un peu comme à la mode euh
de du de des jeux olympiques,
là toujours plus fort, la
technologie. Nous allons avoir
Xavier Barret, on compte sur
vous pour nous expliquer
exactement sur son document là
Il ne parvient pas à retrouver.
Je cherchais la page, la page
quarante-quatre quarante-cinq.
Voilà. L'arbitrage à la Coupe
du monde. Son guide de la Coupe
du monde, il y aura tout et on
vous parlera donc du hors-jeu
semi-automatique. Xavier eh ben
en fait c'est simplement
actuellement quand euh il y a
un but sur hors-jeu pour euh le
définir arrête, on attend que
les gens euh les truquistes
dans le camion mettent les
petites lignes et s'assure en
prenant comme repère euh le
talon du joueur et euh le bout
du pied de l'autre et il trace
les lignes aujourd'hui avec la
technologie, on a ça
automatiquement. Et donc ils
ont déjà fait des tests, il y a
eu récemment d'ailleurs un
match de l'équipe de France où
où ça a été utilisé et
maintenant c'est en fait autour
des stades vous avez plein de
puces partout maintenant pour
euh mesurer les déplacements
des joueurs euh les kilomètres
qu'ils ont faits il suffisait
d'adapter cette technologie
pour pouvoir avoir non plus une
ligne à tracer mais carrément
un espèce de mur virtuel qui
définit si vous êtes en
position de hors-jeu ou pas, et
ça donne des images étonnantes,
j'en ai mis une eh bien vous
voyez ce que ça donne et là
c'est vous avez pratiquement en
trois dimensions euh vous voyez
le joueur qui est le plus en
avance sur l'autre. Ce que ça
veut dire semi-automatique. Ça
veut dire qu'en fait la
technologie vous avez pas
besoin de demander à quelqu'un
dans le car de tracer des
lignes. Ça se fait quand
toujours aux arbitres à l'être
humain. Deux tranchées
absolument et c'est le principe
de l'assistance vidéo euh la
formation arrivera dans
l'oreillette des arbitres euh
de touche hein des des arbitres
assistants qui pourront la
répercuter ensuite à l'arbitre
de Xavier . Mais lui il n'aura
pas directement l'information
de d'arbitrage
semi-automatique. Ce qu'on
pourrait rêver d'un jour où euh
l'info elle lui arrive
directement. Un peu comme pour
euh quand euh la montre vibre.
Après le avantages et et on l'a
vu ces derniers temps en ce qui
concerne le le hum le problème
du hors-jeu, c'est que le gros
avantage, c'est que on laisse
l'action se dérouler pour aller
jusqu'au bout et on revient
pour valider ou non le but,
c'est ce qui se passe souvent.
Et puis parfois finalement
l'arbitre au bout de deux
minutes de de ballon voilà et
et on là on aura la réponse
immédiatement. C'est-à-dire que
si vous partez en contrat vous
voyez bien sûr pour la
dynamique du jeu, c'est
beaucoup plus intéressant.
Frédéric ils aiment euh cette
technologie toujours plus euh
toujours plus importante, nos
nos auditeursEst-ce que ça
les intéresse déjà parce que
l'AVA euh on en a beaucoup
parlé, on la critique aussi
souvent. Ils ils réagissent
mais ils nous parlent un petit
peu de ce qui s'est passé cette
semaine et d'un certain match
de Ligue des champions, une
terre de Milan, Barcelone et
ils interpellent Rémy euh comme
Florent Dinal vous dit, il a
Kinshasa, il parle du FC VAR
qui pleure pour un penalty non
sifflé, bon. Voilà le FC
Barcelone. Ouais. Bon. est-ce
que vous trouvez ça bien quand
on aille toujours plus loin du
côté de la technologie ou
est-ce que on ne fait plus
confiance à l'être humain? Il
faut aller plus loin, plus loin
parce que d'ailleurs qu'on aura
plus d'arbitres euh euh en
êtres humains, on aura plus que
des machines? Je suis quand
même surpris euh et fort
heureusement que Xavier Barret
finira par s'appeler Xavier
parce que voilà le type qui
était derrière Michel Platini
pour dire que non il ne fallait
pas cette technologie et j'ai
passé mon temps ici à crier
qu'il faut cette technologie.
Aujourd'hui, il y a pour vendre
son livre, on va faire comme
ça, après ça va, l'ombre va
s'allonger comme ça et après
l'autre se va comme ça et après
ce sera semi-urbé. Eh Xavier Je
vais te dire une chose et je le
répète loin parce que il y a
des gens qui étaient achaïques,
à savoir par exemple que il
faut savoir quand même que
lorsqu'on parle du réfri
c'était d'abord dans des
tribunes et puis c'est venu en
c'est-à-dire que directement
vous voyez que juges de touche.
toucher. Je vais vous dire. Euh
pourquoi est-ce que il n'y a
pas euh surenchère? Parce que
je vais vous dire que les gars
de la et même de la ils ont
voulu continuer à maintenir le
flou l'opacité parce que vous
vous rendez compte que le 8
mars 2008 ils ont dit ils
rejettent toute la et ils vont
désigner deux arbitres
supplémentaires. Or moi je vous
dis, prenez le cas du Cameroun,
à la Coupe du monde, les petits
pays, qu'est-ce qu'on fait?
Vous marquez votre but, un
arbitre décide de leur refusé
comme on avait refusé le but de
Roger Milla contre le Pérou et
du coup le Cameroun n'a pas été
qualifié. C'est-à-dire que
quand l'être humain décide il
peut il est il peut à l'instant
pour les petits pays, vous
dites que c'est bien. C'est une
très très bonne chose, c'est la
technologie qui va décider que
les autres vont aller dans les
antichambres. Dire que bon,
écoutez, le petit pays là, il
va partir, nous, on va faire
que l'Italie aille gagner
finalement, la Coupe du monde
est la l'Italie avait gagné.
Alors que l'Italie devait être
éliminée dès le premier tour.
tournage vidéo. Non à Xavier
Barret que Xavier ne parte avec
Michel Platini, me demander
pardon. Préparation ça
n'empêche pas certaines
décisions euh parfois quand on
l'a vu lors de Cameroun Comores
à la dernière Coupe d'Afrique
des nations. Mais bon, euh non,
ce qui se passe c'est qu'en
fait à partir du moment où on a
mis le doigt effectivement dans
l'engrenage de l'assistance
technologique, il faut pas euh
s'arrêter en plein milieu du du
du guet. Euh on a vu qu'il y
avait des choses perfectibles,
notamment et beaucoup de gens
se plaignent de tant de
décisions. Du moment où
aujourd'hui on a des des
développements de la
technologie pour l'assistance
vidéo permettent d'avoir des
des euh outils plus rapides,
plus précis, plus efficaces
notamment pour le hors-jeu, eh
bien on va pas s'en priver et
la Coupe du monde est la
meilleure vitrine pour pour euh
les utiliser. Il y aura une
douzaine de caméras dédiées à
cela qui seront placées euh
au-dessus euh de du stade, du
toit du stade et on aura
vingt-cinq vingt-neuf points de
fixation sur un corps justement
pour des et une rotule Rémi
pourra faire annuler un but. En
tout cas la série A qui euh a
l'Italie en tout cas ne va pas
à la Coupe du monde eh bien
aimerait bien tester ce nouveau
système avant la Coupe du
monde. C'est ce que nous a dit
notamment notre correspondant
Matteo Chofy. On continue dans
ce Café des sports.
que mon professionnel
il nasse
atención llegó el momento de
decir adiós.
Ana Josevic de Gonzalo Higuaín
eh la rota el pepita de
Gonzalo Higuaín sa carrière, il
a 34 ans, même si il continue
encore à jouer puisque il joue
dans le championnat des
États-Unis, à l'Inter Miami et
que la saison se terminera en
fin d'année civile et
d'ailleurs avec son doublé il a
qualifié son club dans, c'est
le le club de de David Beckham,
il a réussi à les qualifier
pour ce qu'on appelle les
playoffs. Alors l'international
Xavier rangera ses crampons -8
années de carrière, Rémi, il a
joué dans les plus grands
clubs, le buteur, le numéro
neuf, il il dit d'ailleurs il a
une très belle phrase sur le
numéro neuf, il dit personne
n'est plus proche de la beauté
qu'un numéro neuf. Est-ce que
euh contre Saloï euh pour vous
euh a été un un buteur
frappant, marquant qui a marqué
les esprits? Beaucoup ouais
surtout même euh son passage
euh au Real Madrid, il a quand
même été aussi beaucoup
impressionné. 12-et1 buts.
Voilà, justement, ce n'est pas
n'importe qui qui vient jouer
au Real Madrid et qui s'impose
quand même. Donc moi je crois
quand même que c'est quelqu'un
aussi qui a été victime de
beaucoup d'ingratitude dans son
pays parce que on lui impute
maintenant la défaite euh voilà
donc euh moi je crois que. Mais
lui sur le joueur sur ce buteur
euh euh qui était pas
spécialement élégant mais il
n'avait pas besoin d'être
élégant encore mais il était
c'était c'est on appelle ça un
renard des surfaces. Euh vous
voyez c'est à peu près comme à
l'âne d'une épée élégant mais
quand il faut marquer le but
c'est ce qu'on demande à un
attaquant de fer. Il faut
marquer à toutes les positions.
Il refaisait et de sur quoi il
était aussi bien sûr euh
l'objet de tête et de sur quoi
c'est quelqu'un qui n'a jamais
ménagé des efforts pour être le
premier rideau défensif. Or,
qu'est-ce qu'on voit avec
beaucoup d'attaquants?
Lorsqu'il perd de la balle, il
se ménage. Or lui, il n'a fait
ça, il a toujours été dans le
harcèlement et il a souvent été
attentif donc moi je dis que
c'est un très grand attaquant
qui malheureusement peut-être
n'a pas connu les sommets de la
gloire dans son pays. Euh en
tête du jour avec l'équipe de
France. Alors parce que il est
il faut rappeler une chose et
je le rappelle dans mon guide
de la Coupe du monde, il fait
il est né à Brest et il fait
partie des quatre-vingt-seize
joueurs qui son père et Xavier
effectivement a joué à Brest et
c'est là qu'il est né et il
fait et Raymond Domenech avait
cherché à le français, enfin le
faire jouer pour l'équipe de
France. Il a voulu le
convoquer. Voilà. Et et donc il
fait partie des cinq ou 6 mois
à Brest sa carrière à River
Plate quand on joue à River
Plate, on peut jouer que euh
dans la sélection Argentine
hein. Dis donc il fait partie
des quatre-vingt-seize joueurs
nés en France qui ont joué la
Coupe du monde pour d'autres
pays. D'ailleurs je l'ai dans
mon guide et je vous le je vous
le donne Annie. En direct de
radio écoute. Et donc donc non
c'est du coup du coup il a joué
pour l'équipe d'Argentine et le
est-ce qu'il paradoxal, c'est
qu'il a réussi à s'imposer dans
une équipe à côté de Lionel
Messi, mais dont le partenaire
préféré de de Lionel Messi
était plutôt El Kun Aguero. Eh
oui. Donc deux deux
avant-centre euh pour une seule
place avec des des des profils
très différents. El Koun
c'était vraiment la vitesse.
Higuaen c'était plus un
avant-centre traditionnel euh
qui est plus à l'affût et et
c'était plutôt lui qui avait
les préférences des
sélectionneurs successifs. Il a
été en finale de la Coupe du
monde avec Messi en deux-014.
Il a raté ces fameux buts et il
aurait pu devenir héros euh
s'il avait marqué ces ces ces
occasions qu'il a eues contre
euh Manuel Neuer de héros, il
est il est devenu un mauvais
héros justement le pauvre et
alors euh une euh curiosité euh
que j'ai trouvée euh dans dans
dans la presse c'est que euh le
hum quotidien sportif Xavier
qui s'appelle Olé à Buenos
Aires eh bien tous les ans euh
depuis le 13 juillet 2014 et
cette finale perdue au Maracana
face à l'Allemagne euh par
l'Argentine eh bien le magazine
revenait sans arrêt sur cette
finale. Et malheureusement en
revenant sans arrêt il revenait
donc sans arrêt sur euh ce but
manqué à la vingt-et-unième
minute dans le face-à-face avec
Manuel Neuer. Eh bien quand euh
euh Pipita a a annoncé qu'il
raccroche les crampons . Le
lendemain l'éditorial était
quand même merci et pardon.
Parce que euh effectivement
d'avoir un peu remué autant le
couteau dans la plaie, il
l'était euh dans cette
génération Messi, il a disputé
trois finales quand même,
certes, qui n'ont pas été
gagnées, mais quand même il a
disputé trois finales.
Frédéric, quand on préparait
l'émission, on se disait, il
fait partie malheureusement
galaxie de joueurs qui ont euh
comme euh une euh pas une tâche
mais une petite marque comme ça
sur leur carrière parce que non
seulement ils n'auront
peut-être pas gagné de titre
suprême, lui il a quand même
disputé beaucoup de finales de
Copa America et de de Coupe du
Monde, mais en plus euh ils ont
raté quelque chose, on pense à
**** Tobago en
quatre-vingt-quatorze quand il
rate le le penalty de la finale
de la Coupe du monde. Mais il a
réussi d'autre chose quand même
non mais c'est vrai qu'il
aurait marqué ce but en finale
de la Coupe du monde, il a eu
euh deux occasions franches
face à Manuel Neuer, je crois
un but refusé pour hors-jeu ça
aurait complètement changé euh
l'image que l'on peut avoir de
lui parce que oui il est passé
euh par les plus grands clubs
euh on a oublié le le Napoli
hein buts en Série A euh c'est
le record en deux-mille-quinze
deux-mille-seize mais euh vous
demandez aux spécialistes du
foot là euh tous ceux qui qui
adorent ce ce jeu est-ce que
Gunzalo Ingohen fait partie des
20 meilleurs attaquants des 30
dernières années je suis pas
sûr hein quelle trace il va
laisser euh l'attachant euh,
certains romantismes bon il lui
manquait ce but en finale de la
Coupe du monde, il l'a pas mis.
Et est-ce que nos auditeurs
Rochelle Beckham euh, hommage à
El Pipi Pipita qui a eu des
hauts et des bas dans sa
carrière et pour une petite
anecdote mon premier fils porte
le nom de Pipita Higuen. Ouais.
Et puis Stéphane Badi qui est à
Garois, Higuen le seul joueur
qui a fait pleurer Messi et
l'Argentine en deux-mille14.
Attendez, donc c'est lui qui
fait peur un Messi. En 20dix
qui fait pleurer Messi. Non.
Mais s'il n'était pas là, à la
Coupe du monde en Afrique du
sud, je vais quand même dire
qu'il faut cesser de dire
toujours que ceci et cela. Et
d'ailleurs je vais dire non.
Frédéric quand il se fait le
porte-parole attendez mais
c'est c'est lui qui choisit le
message hein, c'est monsieur
est très vicieux.
l'Argentine a eu les grands
attaquants. Que dites-vous des
Thérèse? Non! Que dites-vous de
non! Que dites-vous maintenant,
même on a remplacé Messi comme
avant-centre! Nous l'oubliez
pas! Et entre temps, il perdait
des finales de ces trois
finales! On n'a pas pu les
gagner! Ce n'était pas Gunzalo
et Gun, vous parlez d'une
action qui ne t'est pas
construite! Il est surpris!
Ouais! Justement dans cette
Xavier c'est comme ça, tout le
monde peut les, peut les rater
parce que c'est pas une action
construite. Oui mais c'est et
vous en faites tout un tam-tam!
Je sais
avez toujours voulu
la Coupe du monde prendre la
balle, Xavier marquer quand
même le cinéma vous dites cra
Allez! Et puis tout! Mais
monsieur c'est vrai! C'est la
technique comme on dit, le
proverbe africain qu'il a volé
le grain de maïs ou pas, on
coupe toujours la tête du coq!
Ouais! Voilà là! Mais Xavier
pour terminer. Non mais
l'histoire de la Coupe du monde
justement elle est faite de qui
ont raté les rendez-vous. Euh
Cruz quelque part bah il va en
jusqu'en finale en
soixante-quatorze avec les
Pays-Bas, une équipe
magnifique, ils perdent euh
barbossa le gardien brésilien
qui qui se trouve deux fois
contre l'Uruguay en
mille-neuf-cent-cinquante, il
il prend deux pas votre livre.
C'était un gardien Xavier eh
bien toute sa vie jusqu'à sa
mort, il a été maudit parce
qu'il a été associé RFI parce
qu'elle est avec les Français
en quatre-vingt-dix-huit mais
il y avait Zizou ils ont été
champions du monde. Et on a
oublié allez on continue on
termine vite sur les cartons de
la semaine. Carton jaune. Un
carton jaune. Oh là là là là,
carton rouge, carton rouge.
Dans la confusion. Carton vert.
Extraordinaire. Rien à dire.
Les cartons de nos auditeurs
tout de suite sélectionnée par
David Finzel. Salut Radio Foot,
salut Annie. Moi c'est David
cette semaine je donne un
carton rouge au football
indonésien à cette violence
qu'on a connu récemment lors du
débit qui s'est déroulé là-bas
franchement c'était pas du tout
bien, ça ne nourrit pas du tout
le football, pas du tout pas du
tout. Carton rouge à la police
indolocienne, carton rouge aux
supporters qui envoient le
stade et puis cartons rouge à
la violence faite aux
supporters. Merci. C'est
Emmanuel le au Gabon. Bon c'est
mon premier carton et mon
carton sera de couleur rouge.
Et il s'adresse Paris et à
toutes les autres villes mais
surtout à Paris, toutes ces
villes-là qui boycottent la
Coupe du monde. La Coupe du
monde a été donnée au Qatar
depuis 20dix. Ça fait déjà 12
ans. Donc ce n'est pas à
quelques mois de de de
l'événement qu'on va se mettre
à boycotter celui-ci. À vous
aussi, ici en Côte d'Ivoire
situé à Abidjan. Mon carton
c'est le carton vert à l'équipe
de Chelsea. Les Belges face à
Milan. On avait très besoin de
cette victoire-là. Oui.
programme
Café des sports depuis le Congo
Brazzaville, je donne un carton
vert au Club Bruges trois
matchs juillet, neuf points
gagnés, sept buts marqués, zéro
buts encaissés, FC Bruges,
carton vert. Bonjour équipe de
Café des sports, c'est Roseline
Vendaï depuis la République
démocratique du Congo. Je
Xavier à Erling à Londres pour
avoir inscrit un triplé et
délivré deux passes décisives
lors du derby rappelons que
c'est le premier joueur euh de
l'histoire de la Premier
League, inscrire trois triplés
consécutifs à domicile. Bon
Café d'Espoir. Moi c'est Sarah
depuis le Burkina Faso dans la
ville de Wayouya, supporter
numéro un du PSG. Je donne un
verre à Lionel Messi qui a fait
un très bon match contre le
bénéficat hier. Chapeau à
Lionel Messi. C'est moi en RDC.
Carton vert au gardien début
camerounais André Onana, qui a
été décisive sur les
importantes actions du Barça.
Lors du match du mardi, qui
s'est soldé par la victoire de
l'Inter un à zéro. Ceci est une
bonne chose pour le Cameroun
qui a pour objectif d'aller le
plus loin possible lors de la
Coupe du monde. C'est Baye
Labbé pour ce Café des sports,
j'ai donné un carton vert à
cette belle équipe du Napoli.
Euh en ligue des champions,
c'est Xavier en championnat,
c'est 8 buts. Franchement on en
parle pas assez mais c'est
l'une des plus belles équipes
en Europe en ce début de saison
si ce n'est la meilleure.
Bonsoir bon soit notre cher
président c'est depuis un
carton fer à toute l'équipe du
Real Madrid qui a gagné encore
le
il est vert et adressé à la
sélection Haïtienne masculine
des amputés qualifiés pour les
demi-finales de la Coupe du
monde des amputés qui se
déroule du côté de la Turquie.
Bonjour
Café
malgré sa défaite en Ligue des
champions pour lui dire il va
se décourager, tôt ou tard il
va savoir se qualifier. Allez
Xavier motif Xavier qu'on
avance allez Rémi ne te montre
pas ça hein s'il te plaît ton
café d'espoir ou bonne émission
bonjour RFI bonjour France deux
je m'appelle David je vous suis
depuis la RDC et ma Xavier qui
fête son anniversaire
aujourd'hui je vous donne mon
parce que vous êtes les maires,
nous vous souhaitons bonne
émission à tous. Ah, c'était
mignon. Et son Adorable tous
nos auditeurson a pu entendre
un coq de Côte d'Ivoire, on a
pu entendre un on a vu des
bouteilles de de vin aussi,
quelqu'un qui nous téléphonait
de sa cave merci à tous et
bravo à Emmanuel Dugabon hein,
qui a envoyé son premier euh,
carton eh ben, qu'il continue,
c'était très bien. Avec lui et
moi. Pour cent d'accord avec de
et je fais Xavier à tous ces
maires des villes françaises
qui tout d'un coup se drapent
d'une éthique nouvelle,
soudaine, en refusant
d'organiser des fanzones euh
pour euh euh la Coupe du monde.
Alors il y a plein de bonnes
raisons de pas Xavier de fan
zone pendant la Coupe du monde
au Qatar. Il fait froid, c'est
le mois de novembre, il faut
faire des économies d'énergie
euh il y a des problèmes de
sécurité donc ça coûte cher de
mettre des vigiles partout. On
a plein de bonne raison de pas
faire de fan zone mais pas qui
nous l'histoire du Qatar et des
ouvriers morts sur les Xavier,
c'est dramatique, mais on se
réveille maintenant alors que
la Coupe du Monde a été
attribuée au Qatar, il y a 12
ans! Non mais, ils sont
vraiment pitoyables ces
mères-là, carton rouge à eux.
Vous êtes Rémi! Alors, euh
carton jaune, c'est Pascal
Belinda, Belinga de ma page
Facebook Réming Gunners qui
donne le carton jaune au
ministre Xavier des Sports qui
en ont un peu brésilien là
hein, on peut comment est-ce
qu'on peut l'appeler? Claude
Paralinho d'agneau d'agneau
justement parce que nous voilà
qui est en train de nous sortir
une histoire c'est que
effectivement lui il est en
train de rêver de recruter
Carlo Ancelotti qui va
permettre à la Côte d'Ivoire
d'aller remporter la Coupe du
monde. Donc il dit dès que Caro
Angelo tu finit avec le
Réalisation mais attendez vous
n'êtes même pas encore en train
de remporter la CAN et tout et
tout et tout et tout essayez
d'abord de faire quelque chose
comme ça comme le dit un
proverbe africain contente quoi
d'un plat de lapin que tu as
devant toi que d'aller attendre
le lièvre qui court encore en
brousse. Frédéric à vous
rapidement. Ton verre il
pourrait être ministre Xavier
des sports Nicolas Pépé qui se
réveille avec Nice euh bon euh
il arrive d'Arsenal transféré
cet été il a marqué hier en
Ligue Europa la patte gauche de
Nicolas Pépé et son sourire ça
nous fait plaisir de vous voir.
Le carton de Radio Foot est
rouge parce qu'il va aux
joueurs de l'Ajax. Ça va avec
leurs maillots, ils ont refusé
à la fin du match d'échanger
leur maillot avec les joueurs
de Napoli. Alors certes ils
avaient perdu six à un devant
leur public, mais quand même
n'oublions pas, comme le dit
Michel Platini, le football
n'est qu'un jeu. Et il y a des
règles de savoir-vivre, peut-on
dire? C'est la fin de ce café
des sports vite vite oui, on
est obligés de se dire déjà au
revoir, bon week-end à tous,
j'espère que vous avez ce qu'a
fait des sports bien serrés,
bien servis et on vous dit à la
semaine prochaine.